[Music]  we love her we sure do and she is out to  kick cancers butt y'all but Melanie  Griffith she just revealed that she has  a battle with a brain disorder the  sixty-year-old revealed she was  diagnosed six years ago after suffering  seizures while on a yacht in Cannes  [Music]  speaking at the woman's brain Health  Initiative panel with moderator Sharon  Stone on Wednesday Griffith says the  seizures were triggered by the stresses  of everyday life at the time she was  still married to Antonio Banderas  meanwhile four weeks after her breast  cancer diagnosis Julia louis-dreyfus  gave us a health update via Instagram  the veep star posted this photo of  herself looking tough with her penciled  in mustache and declaring chemo number  two finito her anthem in this fight she  quoted Katy Perry's rule  [Applause]  [Music]